Ross and I wanna play a game
and win some money for the audience.
(audience cheering)
(Ross giggling) All right, then I guess that means yes.
(Ross giggles)
Let's do this.
As you can see, we have teamed up with Kellogg's
for this very special segment.
Now here's how the game works.
Our audience is divided into two teams.
Team Ross.
(audience cheers and applauds)
That's a good looking team.
And Team Drew.
(audience cheering and applauding)
I know
Wow guys!
It's on Barrymore!
Oh, it is on Rossy Ross Matthews!
All right.
We're each gonna reveal something about ourselves
and the other person has to guess if it's CeReal,
true
or UnReal, false.
For example, I would say,
I starred in a Kellogg's commercial
when I was six years old.
And if you guess that was CeReal,
you'd be right.
Mm-hmm.
That's right.
That's so crazy.
I'm proud that I'm still working
with Kellogg's 40 years later.
Hey! Welcome back.
(audience applauding)
I know.
I feel really lucky, I'm serious.
I'm not gonna take that for granted.
All right.
Now, for every answer we guess correctly,
we get a point for our team
and we get to take a bite of Kellogg's Frosted Mini-Wheats.
They're my favorite because they have all
the fiber, vitamins and minerals.
I love Raisin Bran too, though.
(Ross laughing)
All right.
Whoever gets the most points
will win $50 gift cards for their entire team.
Let's play CeReal or UnReal.
Yes!
(audience cheers and applauds)(upbeat music plays)
(ding sound)
Cute!
Cute! Giving away money.
All right.
And we want our teams to help us out.
So you all have flower poles right now.
So if you think our statement is true,
join in, hold up the green flower.
But if you think we're lying, hold up the red flower.
You got it?
All right. Let's get started.
I'm up first.
Here is my first one, okay.
I once accidentally called Elizabeth Taylor, Dame Edna.
(Ross giggling)
Is that CeReal or UnReal?
Looks like a lot of people think you did.
I feel like I wanna go with the audience on this.
Everybody thinks that you did,
so I'm gonna say CeReal.
(bell dinging)
I'm right?
You're right.
(audience cheering)
well done, Team Drew.
Great going guys!
You get to have a bite of the cereal.
Please allow me, let me please explain very quickly.
You know, I didn't know I was gonna interview
Dame Elizabeth Taylor.
And they said you have to call her Dame.
And I was like, oh,
like Dame Edna.
And when I walked in and I just said
Dame Edna Elizabeth Taylor,
and it went downhill from there.
So, sorry.
(Ross giggles)
All right.
I spent a week at the real Grey Gardens house
before I made the movie, Grey Gardens.
CeReal or UnReal?
What do you guys think?
Yeah, mostly green out there.
So I'm gonna say CeReal.
(bell sounds)
Yes!
(audience cheers and applauds)
We get a point.
I did.
It was the coolest thing ever to
sleep with Jessica Lange at the real Grey Gardens.
And we rehearsed the whole movie in the house
for a week with our director, Michael Susi.
Wow!
I know.
So yeah, that was very cool.
Well, we are tied, one-to-one.
Alright, anybody's game.
Here's my next one.
Drew, I speak three languages fluently.
Is that CeReal or UnReal?
Wow.
(audience laughs)
Okay, for starters,
how dare all of you?
(audience laughing)
I'm gonna go with the audience on this one.
Not because I don't love you Rossy,
but in three languages, that's hard.
UnReal.
(bell ding sounds)
(audience applauds and cheers)
You know,
Next time maybe they should put two languages.
You know, I was rooting for half of you.
I was.
Yeah, I don't speak three languages.
I'm working on that one though.
Working on that one.
(Ross, Barry and audience laugh)
Steven Spielberg made me wait until
I was 10 years old to Pierce my ears.
CeReal or UnReal?
Why do I feel like that?
I'm gonna say that CeReal.
You got it! (bell dings)
Yes! (audience applauds)
All right.
This the last question,
when I was 14 and I got my first apartment,
Frosted Mini-Wheats were basically all I ate.
CeReal or UnReal?
I think that's CeReal.
(bell sounds)
Yes!
(audience cheers and applauds)
That is when I named them, FMW's,
and I have to say, I really have a deep affinity for it.
It makes me feel very comforted
and it's absolutely delicious, and nutritious.
Agreed, Agreed.
All right, Team Ross.
Oh, is the winner.
(audience applauding and cheering)
Your welcome
No, but come on Drew.
I mean my team's all gonna win
but what about everybody else?
Everybody's gonna win today.
Yes!
(audience cheering and applauding)
Our entire studio audience is going home
with $50 gift cards.
Each and every one of you,
please spend it and think of us.
And Kellogg's when you do and do something
that makes yourselves happy.
And thank you for coming here today
and playing this game with us.
And Ross, I will hang with you over
a bowl of cereal any day.
And sharing a bowl of Kellogg's Raisin Bran
or Frosted Mini-Wheats with a friend is such a fun way
to kick off your morning with joy, laughter,
and it helps fuel your day with fiber.
(upbeat music plays)